the Borg are back with a Wi-Fi Gambit
did their master plan pay off or did our
old Heroes send them back to the drawing
board here's how it All Shook out on the
finale of Star Trek Picard warning
spoilers ahead
hope has been a central enduring message
throughout Star Trek the card and it
rings just as true as the series ends
when we first reconnect with them as a
retired World weary winemaker in season
one Jean-Luc piccard seems to have lost
his hope in the future Mankind and
himself thanks to visits from a young
Android in season one an immortal
trickster in season 2 and a desperate
call for help from an old friend in
season three the card has finally
realized that hope is never truly lost
in the final episode the last generation
the Borg have returned and assimilated a
vast majority of starfleets Earth is
about to fall but Picard has reassembled
his old crew pulled the USS Enterprise D
out of mothballs and set a course to
stop them however the board Queen has an
unexpected Ally Jack Crusher son of
Picard and Beverly Crusher he's
inherited his father's Borg assimilated
DNA and is acting as the voice of the
Borg Collective Now the Earth is is on
the verge of Destruction and all the
younger Starfleet officers have been
assimilated through that same board DNA
things look as hopeless as they've ever
been but Federation president Anton
Chekhov has one last message for the
people of the Federation hope is never
lost
there are always possibilities
one of the major themes of season three
has been Evolution first we meet vatic a
changeling whose Rogue faction of
shapeshifters have abilities born from
the torture they endured at the hands of
federation scientists we also meet a
reborn data he's the new Android infused
with the personalities of data and all
of his family once data integrates all
of his personalities into one new
identity it represents an evolution of
his former self as his creator puts it
evolution is not an act of
preservation
[Music]
it's addition
in the last generation the card finally
comes face to face with the board Queen
he learns that the collective has been
weak and vulnerable since Picard's last
encounter with them thanks to their
alliance with the changelings though
their new Collective no longer requires
assimilation at all or even the
combination of machine and biology they
can propagate genetically with the
federation's young becoming a new
generation of Borg however the Borg only
evolved to survive rather than grow and
that turns out to be their weakness
season three of Picard hasn't just been
about the reunion of the Next Generation
crew the story of seven of nine also
takes center stage and comes to its
conclusion in the last generation it
fulfills an arc that began all the way
back in Star Trek Voyager since she left
the board collective in season four of
that series seven has struggled to find
her place in season one of Picard we
discover that seven has joined a group
of Rogue Marshals called the Fenris
Rangers before finally agreeing to join
Starfleet at the end of season two but
her time aboard the USS Titan as first
officer isn't always Pleasant frequent
clashes with Captain Shaw whose personal
resentment of her Borg nature makes him
icy towards her leaves her feeling
isolated and alone ultimately she's
unsure if Starfleet is where she belongs
but by the end of the Borg Invasion Shaw
is killed leaving seven in command in
the last generation she Rises to the
occasion with the help of Rafi she
retakes the bridge from board control
after discovering the Picard is
attempting to shut down the enemy Beacon
she develops a plan to buy Earth Time by
disrupting the board-controlled fleet
embracing her inner Captain Janeway
seven even gives an inspiring pep talk
to her ragtag crew demonstrating just
how far she's come
though the Fanfare around season 3 of
Star Trek Picard mostly regards the
return of the Star Trek the Next
Generation crew the season also adds a
major new character Jack Crusher the son
of Jean-Luc Picard and Beverly Crusher
he's lived most of his life biting by
his mother's side on the fringes of the
Federation but as he got older Jack knew
he was different he suffered from
sleepless nights and disturbing dreams
and struggled to find meaning in his
life eventually Jack experiences waking
hallucinations in Vox he comes face to
face with the board Queen and finally
realizes why he suffers these spells
he's inherited some of his father's Borg
altered DNA and his physiology is being
used by the queen as a kind of
transmitter to control the newly
assimilated Borg drones once he's
connected to the Borg hive mind Jack
binds the one thing he's always sought
belonging like the queen who spent years
as a solitary Collective Jack has
suffered endless loneliness in his life
now he finds finds a sense of meaning
and purpose with the board
the role of family is Central to season
three of Star Trek the card and the
Revelation that Jean-Luc Picard has a
son with Dr Crusher isn't the only way
it's expressed you are going to get us
all killed why are you doing this
because he's my son when the crew
reconnects with Geordi laforge now a
Commodore and director of the fleet
Museum he's also having some serious
family problems his daughter Sydney is a
Helmsman aboard the USS Titan and she
doesn't have the best relationship with
him when she puts her career and her
life on the line to help the card
against the changelings she makes it
clear that her crew is her family then
during the climax of the Season aboard
the Borg Cube the card is joined by
Riker and Wharf on a mission to disable
the Borg Beacon but when they discovered
that destroying the beacon will result
in the destruction of the cube the card
realizes he can't leave his son behind
it's then that he relinquishes his role
as Starfleet officer a role he's
repeatedly said is all he needs to be a
father and save his son when confronted
with Jack's decision to stay with the
board Collective the card decides to
stay and die with him it's this act of
paternal sacrifice that convinces Jack
to disconnect from the hive mind in the
end Picard a man who never wanted or
needed a family of his own not only has
one but understands how important family
is whether it's a blood family or a
found family everyone from 7 to Rafi to
Picard accepts that it truly means more
than anything
more than 30 years ago in The Best of
Both Worlds Jean-Luc Picard is
assimilated by the Borg to become their
leader locutus as a borg Picard helps
the collective wipe out an entire
Starfleet Armada at the infamous Battle
of wolf 359 and is responsible for
thousands of deaths since then the
physical scars of his assimilation have
healed but Picard remains haunted by the
incident Star Trek first Contact allows
him a measure of Revenge on the board
but season three of the card sees him
finally come to terms with his past in
the finale the card destroys the board
Queen which signals the end of the Borg
forever and he accepts that his time is
locutus does not define him he no longer
needs to carry the burden of that trauma
because it's who he is now and what he
does today that really matters the card
isn't the only one who learns this
valuable Life Lesson by the end of the
finale Rafi who has long struggled with
addiction and past mistakes does the
same thing in rising up the to help save
the Federation she accepts that who she
can be is more important than who she
was that warp is able to help her get
recognition for her heroics makes her
growth that much more impactful be happy
with your family
Rafaela Warrior of the House of Massacre
you can't talk about season three of
Picard without mentioning the return of
the Enterprise D restored after its
destruction in Star Trek generations the
last generation sees the Enterprise D
back in action fighting The Board
despite being decades old the Enterprise
manages to hold its own against the Borg
when the collective trains the Cube's
weapon on the famous Starship with the
help of Dr Crusher who's had a lot of
practice fighting off foes over the last
20 years they're able to take out their
weapons A lot's happened in the last 20
years
when Riker and Wharf send them the
location of the Borg Beacon however it's
up to the revived data and his gut
feelings to Pilot them inside the Borg
Cube and take it out but with the card
locked in an existential struggle for
control of his son jack getting them out
before Earth is destroyed by the Borg
might be impossible and a heartbreaking
Choice the remaining crew of the
Enterprise agrees that they have to
sacrifice Wharf Riker Picard and Jack to
save the Federation however Deanna Troy
senses her husband's location and they
are able to beam their stranded crew up
just before the Borg vessel is destroyed
in the episode's conclusion we learned
that the Enterprise D has taken its
rightful place as an exhibit at the
fleet Museum
the cast of Star Trek TNG is tied
together by close friendships both on
the show and in real life in the world
of Star Trek though most of the
Enterprise's crew haven't seen each
other in years but season three of
Picard sees them all come back together
when Picard receives a cry for help from
Dr Beverly Crusher by the end of the
last generation it's clear that these
renewed friendships aren't going to be
dissolving anytime soon the new and
improved data gets counseling from
Deanna Troy which helps him realize that
being human is as difficult and complex
as aspiring to be human meanwhile Picard
and Dr Crusher appear to be happy
co-parents if not more the finale
solidifies the fact that this crew is a
family now and forever and will remain
close but the series finale is about
more than a renewal of bonds it's about
new ones too Warf makes his friendship
with Rafi clear calling her a fellow
Warrior meanwhile S7 takes command of
her own Starship we see the Newfound
friendships she's made with her new
crewmates Sydney laforge Jack Crusher
when showrunner Terry matalis set out to
craft season 3 of Star Trek Picard a
part of his motivation was to give the
TNG crew the proper send dog while fans
will debate the finer points of the
effort it's clear that matalus achieved
his goals following the time Jump a year
past Frontier day the crew gathers a
gainan's 10 forward bar in Los Angeles
for a celebratory drink while Riker and
Troy plan a vacation and toasts are
given beta gets in half a joke a
throwback to episode 2 of TNG and Dr
Crusher urges Wharf to sing a little
Klingon Opera there was a young lady
from Phoenix
police wanted to finish this to cap off
the night Picard proposes a friendly
game of poker this calls back to the
card games they played for years as a
close-knit crew the episode's final
scene also mirrors the closing shot of
the series finale all good things as
they settle their hands and Picard
collects his spot the overhead camera
pulls out and the iconic Star Trek
Fanfare begins it signals the true end
for the stories of the crew of the
Enterprise d
when season three of Star Trek Picard
was first announced as the conclusion of
the series fans expected it to tie up
all loose ends and bring an end to the
character of Jean-Luc Picard with the
return of the TNG crew it wasn't
unreasonable to think that this was
going to be the final appearance of that
cast some thought that the finale might
even feature the shocking death of one
or more of the crew members but in the
last generation not only does the entire
crew make it out alive but there are
also clear setups for future Adventures
Captain Tubac having survived the
changeling conspiracy gives seven the
good news that she's been promoted to
captain of the newly commissioned USS
Enterprise G at her side is first
officer Rafi elmsman Sydney and her
special counsel enzen Jack Crusher it's
a clear setup for a new spin-off one
that showrunner Terry matalis has
already teased audiences are even given
a sneak peek at what could be its first
Adventure in a final mid-credits scene
The Immortal trickster Q returns to warn
Jack Crusher than new trial is about to
begin and this time Picard's son is at
the center of it